[Music]
in creepy data news d'etat bigger data
dad I like data data - where are you
problem west coast to East Coast East
Coast data for you data for Mexico Beta
Beta Montero monkey
Tata submitted by base force huh what'd
you say face horse I'll base our Scott
would you think she said horse a Chinese
database data so maybe you're a data
personal data of yours I think I'm dated
no I thought I was doing it wrong that's
if you if you replay the footage I got
nervous when I said it I wasn't sure
what was the correct they're both
correct in a Chinese the Tata base lists
the breed ready status of 1.8 million
women it doesn't what status breeding
status breeding breed ready status what
the [ __ ] does that mean like this like
like oh she's 18 now or whatever or she
just had her period like that or maybe
like she's ready for a baby like maybe
once you get past your career like
you're 26 and you're ready they're
speculating that it has to do like
either the woman has already had a child
or is of childbearing age Oh what the
[ __ ] does that oh is it because they
have more men than women there now
because they weren't [ __ ] they made
poor choices yeah they're saying that
China has following birth rates it's not
a problem they're kind of overpopulated
but I guess they want now they want to
you reading and any people also their
breeding can be do they want to use it
different like what
breeding I don't know like like animals
breed yeah I'm in to procreate just say
fermented well yesterday look uh this
Dutch internet expert who found this
insecure data cachet and it's full of
1.8 million women and a whole bunch of
personal information including their
phone numbers addresses and the breed
ready status and this is an open
database in China who's it for no no no
just stumbled on it yeah they just
stumbled on it and then so people are
thinking maybe this was from a Hecht
dating service
or maybe like China's keeping tabs on
breed ready women well that's easy
Dabangg evolved I'd find out how many
people are in China like how many women
are in China if it's you know I don't
know how many would be but if it's like
50 million then 1.8 probably is from a
hacked dating web site you know yeah
it's too little because it's I think
they have a billion people yeah and if
there's 50 50 yeah it's so I guess a lot
of people were just saying like this is
disturbing like this this feels like the
Handmaid's Tale where do you guys know
the story behind that so Henry it's a
great show by the way they turned it
into a show it's good yes I read the
budget I saw the show I love the show
anyway so it's about this show got
boring go soak up don't be in kind of
future where people can't have kids
anymore or like there's certain women
that or it's mainly like guys that
aren't fertile anymore and so they
enslave all the women all the women that
can have kids mmm those yeah they are
assigned to like elite families that run
the country now and this is in the u.s.
and and so these women are called
Handmaid's Tale I mean sorry ten maids
and they are assigned to these homes
where once a month when they're fertile
they get [ __ ] by the man of the house
yeah in order to try to get pregnant and
the whole the whole goal here is for for
them to have the baby yeah that's kind
of handmade so so they're saying because
the women can't do it anymore
yeah like women aren't fertile anymore
their wives aren't fertile yeah the
wives aren't fertile on it and then but
then they're kind of saying like well
it's mainly the dudes that aren't
fertile too and then they're just trying
to blame it all on the women it's a
pretty good show anyway I should watch
that I heard it was good give it their
own that's pretty good too III will
watch it I will definitely watch it her
there's a lot of titties on it so oh
jeez what am i doing bad dude
that's medieval bush ooh medieval bush
probably smells nasty and has lice okay
not
granddaughter naked oh really yeah I
told you guys before yeah Oh what that's
Charlie Chaplin she's acting like
Charlie Chaplin in Game of Thrones
that's not like big hook you're not
really hooking me with that that's like
do you get to see Richard Pryor's
granddaughter that's a hook for Casey
yeah for me I'm kinda like I guess like
Cindy Crawford's daughter I'm like oh
because she's hot she's in there
actually had the first few seasons on
DVD
my brother has it he left it up oh just
HBO it dude I'm gonna play a video game
like that and idea even have a DVD
player no I do not
wall the warpath is closest I guess I
thought you meant when were you like
impregnate women there's something from
a book reading day now I rather pretend
to have sex which is I mean I rather
practice having babies okay well pretend
to have sex is jacking off practice
making babies is having sex without
actually planting the seeds it was so
dirty back in the day man like those
medieval times [ __ ] disgusting teeth
it was so nasty to the point where like
uh the leap people would have to walk
around with potpourri in their hand
because the street smelled so [ __ ]
bad oh I did not love that look back
yeah you could see it in Game of Thrones
Gatien they were they were the Greeks or
Romans they bathe regularly if they were
clean and then the Dark Ages happened
and then their [ __ ] health went to
[ __ ] yeah and they thought the [ __ ]
ass Knicks were the savages cause like a
Lulu why'd they take so many showers Oh
the irrigation system so oh yeah
they had a rehab sewage we brought [ __ ]
in the streets these people you don't
[ __ ] where you sleep is how the Saints
supposed to go they're like no you do
sleep where you [ __ ] that's where all
the diseases and things came yeah
because of all the [ __ ] wrath you
just started well cuz no no it's it's um
it's a combination of you know small
communities and then cities starting to
build and when when city started burying
if people are bringing their farm type
of lifestyle into the city they bring
their livestock with them all that stuff
so you have human [ __ ] animal [ __ ] piss
you have fit trash on the streets
everyone
sharing this and in the rats you know
they're getting like diseased and then
the fleas get on the rats and then to
get on the humans and then the bubonic
plague and all that [ __ ] happens I want
to watch like a documentary about the
dark ages now cuz like you know as how
like you knew what happened what
happened like I need like more like why
were that's not gonna drive our history
you knows everything really when the
Roman Empire was big and strong
they had order structure they had a
little bit more hygiene and things like
that they used to take baths they had
luxury all that and now houses probably
beautiful bath houses and then boom they
got like that much corruption too much
yeah and then they wipe themselves out
they divided into three unstable Roman
Empire's that just never recovered and
then these warlords in Europe they took
over and these barbaric warlords took
over it and that's who in like that's
when the game of thrones kind of world
happened where they were like kings and
then landlords and things like that you
had peasants and and that's kind of
where it went down and then people
started moving into cities and and
that's where the Industrial Revolution
kind of happened right at the cusp of it
I skipped the Renaissance and stuff like
that crazy at the same guy that does mud
ablution all the time I mean that's also
so interesting because like I knew it
happened and for some reason I never
cared about history but I'm really into
like the psychology of people and I want
to know like what was going on this
longing and and hygiene and toilet and
things like that so like while Europe
was super sophisticated with the
freaking even like during Napoleon's
like like time and then you know they
have these great palaces and in there
traveling the world they're there
colonizing but they still don't have
toilets in their house in their inner
palace bar people did you know no that's
great wild yeah we had that don't be
like parties right in the winter they're
just the ballroom dancing and [ __ ] and
then there's no bathroom so then they'll
go to the the staircase and then just
hang over the staircase and [ __ ] I'm
sorry to keep read them it's not a joke
anymore but there they would always have
to change out their thing whatever
okay nevermind moving on their [ __ ]
bucket if you go to France and you go to
the Palace of Versailles you'll notice
that they never show you a bathroom
there was no [ __ ] bathroom oh yeah
they had outhouses and they had things
like that later Marie Antoinette had she
had her own bathroom
and then she had a little toilet and
stuff like that's why they had wigs too
cuz of the lice
that's why y'all cuz had no hair natives
were clean yeah we were easy that's so
much technology but nothing in toilet
technology until the Industrial
Revolution that's lazy like I do we well
the like I'm like the tribe that I'm
from it was actually very close to the
water but even people that were more
central in America they still you still
took baths you found water you cleaned
yourself everyone cleaned themselves and
I think why the Lord gives us - like
families would share water which like to
me like that's it's still like kind of
dirty but it like it makes sense it's
like you take what you can but like that
yeah I don't understand people were just
chilling and like having animals [ __ ] is
the center of the Lord it's filthy and
then at what was the breaking point that
they decided to take a bath plague dude
so for years people [ __ ] died so
praying this I don't know when they
decided or when they it became a part of
the culture or what no I'm saying when
in day to day life - taking a bath
become a priority like 30 days 60 days a
hundred days because after a certain
period of time can't you die for all
those people that don't take that's out
there for years they'll recommend a time
during the time like I think it was once
a year but they said if you bathe too
much you get sick that was the common my
god imagine that her perfume the hair
that's why they had wigs and [ __ ] cuz a
life's gone yeah it's really bad yeah
that's what they were heavy on the
perfume disgusting yeah Scott yeah cuz
bathing culture I think there's certain
cultures that always had bathing that's
like but I think Europe had bathing
culture and then it went away and it
came back and in all this stuff because
there's like pictures of Roman you know
bath houses and then it the way that
they designed it it looks crazy it's
like a huge pool with people like in the
bathtub
they would exfoliate their skin and
everything yeah and then underneath
there's like a fire pit and like people
working on it and then stuff like that
but like see in the bathhouses for some
reason to me that still sounds like a
sex thing so it's like only like a sex
thing your figured about a brothel
that's what separated men and women
together yeah and the men would [ __ ]
each other yeah I bet they did
thy butt hole looks fantastic young man
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I
[Music]